un homme de la guitarra Americana starring emilio estefan our ability to have a new civilian
force in our society our medina de la da da da da da da da da
la da da da da da da da da da ba da da da da la
voiture Anna Muhammadan Harvey do I wanna be you who also yeah human latina Aminata Papa
Pato parte de la de Mouton an 11-2 Simon Yelena Zhukova community an otaku mean FC
marquise de boeuf a la commune has a Java bamboo marriage' and Kathy Almanza
what type of water that it s gonna be evil of Han na ma Akane Deva
yeah unilatina amount of wahoo loophole and Sadie de Guzman our medical wealthy like all the
new become woman very suitable for 30 festivals and Harvey
we begin the name of Allah all praise and glory be to Allah Lord of the
Worlds we thank him and who seek his health and his garments and his pleasure in
his forgiveness and we asked him how to protect us from the evil whispers within us
and the evil consequences of our misdeeds from the number of guides no one can lead
astray and remember about leaves or guidance none can guide that person and testify that no
one is worthy of our worship but Allah alone finally partners the true supreme king the
Prophet Muhammad sallallaahu idea Anika said it was in truth his prophet and servant and His
Messenger well people of Eman happens up low of a block remain conscious and obedient to
Allah in the matter he deserves and do not die except in a state of complete
and total surrender to Allah a state of Islam
to begin one of the many many many many merits of Islam
is that it ensures dignity for human being in their behavior
it helps a person become king
calm and collected dignified and composed regardless of what experience circumstances may provoke them or push
to manipulate them if a person is trying to observe Islam correctly they will find it
easier than others
to not have high blood pressure and the totally disgruntled totally angered because the men who
either ruined their basket won't leave with their friends as I heard one elderly man I
estimate using a 65 or 70 years old never forget that he was running up the
court from the Thunder began this was the one day him and his guys get together
and so he looked up at the sky that had to be madness was not a
Muslim and he said we had a deal
angrily shouting out all of us a panic attack you would not be that person that
a good friend of mine who used to work in the Apple store says about that
when the iPhone six came out we had her phone the girl that we could online
for two three hours what she had insisted that it be the pink one and we
weren't going to have that for two three more days she turned a blaze she went
on fire she had a temperature as if she was a child she went from anger
to tears to crying and she leaves the store this time dignifies a person above such
behavior it dignifies a person above the behavior of a person who said to me I
don't care I
will refuse when they ever do that to go to paradise if my wife is inside
I don't care of this problem sends me to the fire my enemy that causes a
person to move not just from adulthood to childhood but from sanity to insanity from belief
to disbelief under controllable anger our team came to help a person beyond that weakness becoming
a victim of their own anger so in Bukhari and Muslim so they met it wasn't
the amount a guy who says his temper are too lenient than a piece of above
ridiculous and lemon whenever you return to you soon
well I have new home and a soup would alpha was dead the hullabaloo la habra
let's go two men got into a fight an argument in front of the profits of
the Maserati of Silla while we were there and one of them kept just cursing offending
the other and
he was in a fit of rage to the point that he became so angry his
face became red we could all see this man was losing it he lost his leaders
basic for fallen the Divas of Olive on ETO settling in Nina Arabic any medicine no
Ghana had ever have our humanity the prophets often have said I know a statement that
if he were to say it all that he finds inside of himself that fury inside
of himself would just vanish with disappear are we will be landing in a shape on
the Ragini's Anessa stated you accessing i seek refuge protection with allah from shaytan the accursed
Ksenia babu so I haven't even MRI image ever of the eleven you can Amman the
beasts of Allah already who said then have an eighty five are who be been one
of us I haven't heard message some of love I didn't say this something was more
eyes on the heart so he went to the man who informed him the messengers of
Allah audience and that said this and
then they said to him to I would be done in this shape on seek refuge
with Allah from Shaitan so how that other budget and so the man retorts it back
to him he snapped back at him at Taranaki betsa image noon even hell you think
there's something wrong something's wrong with me am I am I crazy Shaitaan has possessed me
meaning you think I am possessed by a demon get out of here get away from
leave
and
this hadith of course is filled with lessons and guiding principle some of them being obviously
that a person must be very careful about their timing when they give advice in general
and also of the lessons of this hadith is how to deal with angry people in
particular
but what I want to start with in talking about anger management controlling our anger all
of us and how Islam enabled us to do that and showed us the roadmap out
of this dark this dark sphere of anger that consumes so many people
that the prophets of Allah are either sending them alluded to the fact that anger is
from Shaitaan you have to seek refuge with Shaitaan when you're angry that means they are
the factor at play it is all anger from Shaitaan no
only when its alady huh only when it's unjustified but the issue is usually most of
the time most of us most of our anger is for personal reasons and if it's
you're taking sides for a personal reason you're already gonna be biased and so it's not
going to be for Allah Norah's it's really going to be about fairness and justice because
you cannot be just when we were one of the two disputants and so almost all
of anger because of that equation this front goes back to being from straight line you
feel you assume someone violates your rights
someone has shortchanged you in your reputation so you react with anger how much your active
angular depends on who you are and what happened but not all anglers from Shaitaan we
do need to establish standards and there in and of itself is natural it's completely natural
completely human of us even though I was not a modern concept that just anchors okay
with management of anger that's not just a modern thing that we talk about nowadays in
therapy this is has always been something understood by the wise among humanity even though out
of they used to say man is still labor when I'm the other love for who
are you know like whomever is provoked to anger and doesn't become angry their donkey like
what do you mean you slapped across the face in your final minute that means you're
not alive you're not human you have no self-respect you have you're totally indifferent about even
that are you alive what manager can be making it's in even with the poet says
injuries are only not felled by dead people so long as they're alive the injury is
gonna hurt an injury is going to provoke a reaction from you so the issue of
anger being there is not the problem at all a person is allowed to become angry
and a lot of place anger inside of us when he created us meaning the propensity
to anger he made us prone to anger to test us right how are you gonna
react are you going to contain that natural anger and then how will you employ that
anger because there are two things here there's natural anger you need to control that between
the balance of a volatile environment and there is righteous anger we're not just you're allowed
to have it you should have it angered for Allah but that also of course must
be regulated by the boundaries of Allah as elegant as for not becoming angry whatsoever this
is completely alien to human nature and to Islam even in the Koran Allah Celgene says
about people that he praises that have earned his pleasure he says well even loudly boo-boo
you have firoun people that when they become angry they forgive so he's not praising them
for not becoming angry he's praising them for forgiving despite being angry so the problem with
anger is watch them in it and some of it is even righteous anger the problem
is when it comes from Shaitaan as we said earlier usually it's from shaking
when Shay bond gets anger to control you instead of you controlling it that's one of
the whole dilemma happens when anger controls you and consumes you and blocks your ability to
be sensible to think with your mind right not with your emotions what should I be
doing here what's right and what's wrong here what's very unfair what's pleasing to Allah was
that to block your sensibility that's the problem when it blocks your ability to be patient
your forbearance to block your ability to delivery to measure things for the long term to
think things through as they say those are the problem because these are things that love
demands from you so if anger can hijack these things Shay finally puts you in a
very distant dangerous place because these are not police on my you know in both ID
and Muslim the prophets of Allah are they who send and receive the delegation and the
leader of that delegation was a man by the name of Allah change if not the
place and the entire delegation rushes to meet the Prophet SAW sullen and their leader who's
supposed to go first that represents their chief they left him behind the luggage and the
animals they all rushed in for that protocol because the Prophet SAW said Allah obviously would
make you forget protocol and so their eagerness to meet there are still a lot of
caused them to forget their respect that they lived by the honor of their chief their
chief did not though he tied up the animals and he took off his clothes and
put on nicer clothing even better protocol to go see the prophets of Allah audience send
them in clean attire not patate tyre you've been traveling with all this time and so
the Messenger of Allah saw Allah hasn't noticed is from him and he said to him
in Navi Cohoes Latini yuhibbu whom Allah who and hidden one attempt he said in you
are two qualities that our love loves him
or variants for you to put up with things that make you angry for variants these
people disrespected you they did something that you would naturally anger you but you have hidden
you shove him and and that is the liberation when you sit and think things through
what's the best way to behave here and you're not gonna think things through through angry
so Haven has to come before an app for parents so that you can deliberate
so he thought it through it's better for me to wear my best clothing to wash
up perhaps and then most see the profit some of our body who sent them so
the man was happy and he said the auto salon pas at Tejada left Oh behemoth
and Javon and endeavour on a Hema yeah also what these two qualities are talking about
did I practice these but did I adopt these consciously or did Allah our surgeon create
me this way he made me more prone to deliberation more prompt forbearance and so the
prophets of Allah audio setup said to him Benjamin are innate you might know of what
created you this way some people are more prone saying they're some people don't have that
challenge they will have other challenges certain you don't think you've got the short end of
the stick we will all be tested somewhere in your testing with the short fuse some
have a lust for the opposite genitive some cannot resist wealth and that is their jihad
that is their challenge so he's telling him now this one Allah gives you a freebie
on that one among created you this way with these qualities that he loves forbearance and
deliberation and so he said and happened to be that met each other landed on a
full detainee you hit aluminum block water so he said come to be better Allah gave
me two qualities that human is less that ian is messenger love and so when anger
sensors these for merit deliberation senses and civility into life this is when it's from Shaitaan
and this is what happens more often than not especially in today's world that's why this
hope was so important right in today's world that so fast peace there's so much commotion
there's so much interference right there's so much lack of privacy and there's so much lack
of worship also making our lives god centric centered people will automatically become more angry we
have more angry people now this is known and expected because of our lifestyle less worship
more fast-paced less deliberation less forbearance less the ability to frustrate to tolerate frustrations all of
that it will uproot the tree of your faith and plant among other things plant the
tree called anger it gets wedged in your life and we just become angry people that's
why I see panel of the wisdom of us have understanding this when they read in
the Quran when a kinkou new rock band ye do not be people that just have
the book you just rush past the verses like Venice ye do not be like the
nice lady who just rushes past the verses and not takes care of them not invites
them in their life adopts them in their life but be people of God or better
he needs people of God truly attached to God I believe of the Obama he said
about this and what does it mean to people of God he said two words all
that food I'm mad in the banana people that have forbearance and people that have knowledge
meaning
you are contained because of your relationship with God right your tree of faith is in
there and so you are contained and you know what Allah wants almost like we're married
to deliberation again to know what you're supposed to be doing regardless of the outside circumstances
the opposite when you don't have a god centric life and you have a fast-paced world
it will put the tree in danger when the tree of anger is planted in your
life you can imagine what happens when you're quick to anger this anyone divorced his wife
except when he's angry that's like a common jump between all of the machete that every
time someone says my husband divorced me because I divorced my wife we tell them what
happened he says but but but I was angry we tell them what has anyone ever
divorced their wife over a cup of tea like obviously you are angry why else did
you divorce has anyone ever divorced sent their angry do people insult except that they're angry
do people offend one another slander you're angry at someone who just start thinking it maybe
this and maybe that's all from Trayvon right do people leave Islam they curse at times
the Dean and the home and the claim with his being and the one who sent
down the Quran because they're angry do people kill except because they're angry do people lie
and cheat except to have leverage in the conversation because they're angry all of those sins
of the tongue I just mentioned these are just sour fruits that grow on the tree
of anger when the tree of anger gets planted in your apartment all of it comes
from the same place and that's why our prophets of Allah Quran is no syndrome called
our attention to this they catch it he says to us no hatred in our best
merits by the flood and undergo fraud in that humbly Hadouken finesse scoot when one of
you is angry keep silent because once anger gets settled it just that's when all those
sandwich roots come out you starts using your tongue in all these ways that are so
destructive so dangerous so on you're angry be silent he said and by the way of
course if you're obligated in Islam to be silent when you're angry so that's an escalated
you're definitely not allowed to eat someone not keeping their children on your enemy because if
you hit because you're angry you will not stop hating until you feel a finished or
until you've done something so damaging that it brings you back to your senses around Laguna
and so heating is not allowed to quencher your age in Islam heating is allowed as
a last resort in moderation to discipline not to avenge yourself and if you cannot control
what you're going to say in words are so like and the tongue is so easy
to move that boneless muscle as they say you can't use it when you're angry then
you definitely cannot use your hands and
so this is why he is also said I'm tied between the the tongue and the
anger itself because once that tree is planted elderly sour poisonous fruits continue being spewed out
as a result the whole of only other
anyway
having that work the Seleucid of armament anivia dr.
to the law that would actually connect West London permanent and arbiter who one of the
usual arson and of course once these words when my angers off contained in these words
complying out or may Allah forbid physical ramifications the Stations of the anger take place so
many times the damage as people know is either irreversible cannot be repaired or so hard
to prepare to repair
you know I remember reading that an intelligence father once noticed very early on that his
kid has anger problems and so what he did with him to defuse the situation whenever
his kid would lose his temper he would have him walk out to the end of
their property and and nail a homemade email into the fence to make sure he went
to the end every time he would lose his temper he would send him on the
same task then what was the punishment he says on the first day my son took
38 nails in the fence
he said and gradually the amount of nails he would put in each day was less
and less and less until he finally got to a day when he didn't put any
nails in the fence and so I would tell him for every day you don't lose
your temper you can go remove one nail from the fence
he says without by the time the day came that he actually removed everything from the
fence I took him over to the end of our property to the property line and
I said to him what do you see you can imagine fence filled with holes he
said you undid all of your temper tantrums you earning it that but were you able
to repair the holes in the fence sometimes your anger will cause you to do damage
that you cannot prepare and this is especially true with people and possibly true from us
a pattern all the time sometimes we just blurt things out to say things you do
things and the damage no matter how hard you try people are not gonna love they
will not just forgive you the moment you back to them and so the damage leads
for a very long time I have cases of children that are traumatized from the religion
of their parents from Islam because of the way they saw their parents their father treated
their mother right
the domestic violence the battery that happens when Islam itself and then think of the damage
that happened with so many relationships outside of marriage insight all different kinds so when the
man came to the prophet sallallaahu he will send them and he said to him out
singing this is lame honey give me in at once all of that some books it
don't become angry but Quran have my Agha father that's up top he kept repeating the
question like give me more advice give me more advice he told about becoming don't becoming
do not become angry in the narration of this hadith visit there's an extra word in
a commentary narrated by a talking on love this man says it took me advice he
says Calvin hey Ana Paula and Andy you sallallahu alayhi wa sallam upon the heath album
yes Mary shout McCune level he said when I when he finally refused to give me
any more advice I start to think about it why is he telling me only this
and I realize that this qualities learning me from cautioning me against contains all the evil
inside of it why do you think the Prophet SAW Stalin did give him anymore twice
there are so many other a hadith when he tells people that ask him al cine
advice he gives and different prices he wanted this person and us as well to know
that getting passed don't become angry it's not easy it's a mission right you're not going
to go do it overnight and likewise I say now don't think our problem with anger
in general in our generation in our impulsive or compulsive generation is going to be done
with comfortable and I plan and charm up to give you two more fulness one of
them is inspiration on how there are the Muslims Delta's anger because we kind of identified
other it's natural it's an inspiration it's extremely useful and the third of them how to
deal with angry people but I wanted this whole book to begin on how to deal
with angry me my anger itself how to get past that how to conquer our own
anger the good news is that how to delete that countering your anger is certainly possible
because the problems are said have shown us ways to do it but it's going to
require training not a football as he said is not wassalam in a manner in mauritania
when a man hits a handle when he never saw you lose the support that you
learning knowledge is to learn okay so I'm sorry I'm just not a smart person no
that's easy when I could carve a lot a lot let that go you have to
try to learn whenever you move it's a highly loom and developing forbearance the ability to
restrain anger that's through practicing forbearance trying one time and trying again and slipping and resting
up and apologizing and coming back around well you never saw with the support and patience
is still training yourself conditioning yourself foundations and of the tips that he gave us and
with that I'll close the whole bottom of the tips he gave us on a sloth
was set up to get past to help us in this course in this training course
to get past our anger and all the damage it causes for our dunya and our
team number one is the ayah that we said to seek refuge with Allah from Shaytan
emerging from the cursor shape on this is the first of them the second of them
we say is do not speak when you're angry when you become angry walk out shudders
be silent because one word will lead to a response which will step up your anger
another level it will escalate it so to be silent
number three is for you if you're standing to sit down this Italian sauce a la
valle de la luna yakame phantom orange moon other way enact vania budget when one of
you is then angry and standing let them sit down change positions right
deescalate the situation and this will do a wing with your energy said and if it
doesn't lay down one time they saw a blue member of the 11-hundred was known to
have intense emotions in the middle of a conversation just laid down some there should be
sax and Lenny late then can imagine talking to someone hold the sudden they're just they
sit down and they'll 8000 what are you doing he said I heard the public saw
some say this this is a man who cared what is hereafter and cared about his
relationships that will extend into the Hereafter this is the person who took this mission seriously
not to say hey listen you know I'm an angry person deal with it that doesn't
work the believer that is observant of am on the last day does not sign themselves
off of the mission like that so we said it's the eye and he says be
silent we said if you're standing sit or lay down also read about the virtues of
restraining your anger and they are so many in the Quran of this women our promise
also them said the strong person is actually the first that restrains their anger you're not
out wrestles others he said in another hadith sorry
let's talk about what a continued do not be angry don't get angry at for us
perilous
for a person that wants to get in states a lot in his life that means
something you know if you were angry in about to do something and someone stuck a
gun to your head you'd back off you'd count that something okay okay alright gonna rescue
me don't shoot me don't this right the believers should have you offer agenda to be
one of those light bulbs serving okay definitely worth it fine I'll take the hit I'll
swallow that's our bill I'll do it so to realize the virtues of
restraining your anger and also the flipside of that the dangers of leaving your anger uncontrolled
the last one that I mentioned for this will spot for this whole bunch on mama
and then some and just people have observed an experience when you find yourself angry go
look at yourself in the mirror you want to recognize yourself you'll feel like this is
not to me like it's shaped by the air or like who is this guy who
is this person help yourself psych yourself out if you're angry
as with the other things like the Senate are righteous friend how they dealt with anger
that's inexcusable in sha allah and of course the rod goes all across the board beginning
during and after the mission as our Prophet SAW said I used to say was Anakin
he's in the West End of got cost less alcohol that have to feel a little
bubble and I ask you a true statement to be contained in my words whether I'm
pleased or whether I'm angry and we ask some are subject to help us with this
guy these guiding principles of Islam help us improve our relationships first with him and with
his creation of aam aadmi may Allah make us of those thats a statement of truth
and judge Harry whether we are pleased with whether we are angry we all must Okinawa
trying to bring our hearts together and bring our behavior aligned with the guidance of his
prophets allah la ilaha illa allah wa nahnu homina homina homina homina
the new banner a monofin anikanova Nawaz la da de da da da da da Vanina
Wadena Saguna Sarah Tina Subaru Sarah Magina Mary Lou Marzian o bones of Islam are famously
mean why didn't achieve khaliqeen of mama in America that had a MMA but often a
Donatella Finocchiaro Elena masala wasallam of our economy gentlemen were the heroes of abusive